مهما يكن [تصفيق]
نعم
26. لقد جئنا على طول الطريق من أصدقائنا
إلى الدوحة بالدراجات ، فقد كان 7000
كيلومتر من شارع فريمونت
وكان مذهلاً من البداية إلى
النهاية خاصة مع هذه الصالحة الصالحة للزراعة
هنا في الملعب الخاسر.  نحن
متحمسون جدًا يا رفاق هذا الجنون
قبل عام واحد خلال دوري الأمم
الذي تفكك في إيطاليا وكانت
رحلة رائعة بالنسبة لنا لأننا ذهبنا إلى
هناك بالدراجات وقررنا الذهاب إلى
أبعد من ذلك والذهاب إلى قطر والقيام
بنصف الكرة الأرضية.  كأس 2022
[موسيقى]
من الجنون رؤية هذا
الاستاد المذهل بعد مغادرته مباشرة وليس
بعد ذلك لأنه كان أفضل بثلاثة أشهر
بعد ترك الدراسة في
فرنسا ونأمل أن يكون
مسرح النجم الثالث للرئيس كما نحن
ابدأ الفيلم الذي نحب الأزرق الذي نحب
ركوب الدراجات وركوب الدراجات هو أفضل طريقة
لتغطية مسافات كبيرة ولكن أيضًا لديك الوقت
لمقابلة أشخاص على طول الطريق والتوقف
وقتما تشاء وهي رحلة مدتها ثلاثة أشهر
وبفضل هذه القرية  re
's many Adventures
[Music]
لقد جئنا إلى هنا بالدراجات ، لذا فهذا يعني
أنك تعرف مدى حبنا لليبرالية ومدى قوتنا التي سندعمها ،
كان أفضل جزء من الرحلة هو بعض
المدن المذهلة مثل Istanbul Petra
Jerusalem ، لقد كانت أماكن رائعة
اكتشفنا
[موسيقى]
كان هناك العديد من التحديات خاصة
الآلية والجسدية التي كان علينا ركوبها على
العواصف الرملية وكان علينا الركوب على الجبال
وكان الأمر صعبًا حقًا ولكننا فعلناه لذلك
أعتقد أنه كان ممكنًا لقد
وافقنا عليه لأننا  لست رياضيين ،
كما تعلم ، فنحن مجانين ونعم ،
نتمسك بفكرتنا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
لأن العديد من الفرق الجيدة جاهزة
لهذه البطولة ، لذلك نعتقد أنه
سيكون من المثير جدًا متابعتها
وبالطبع نحن  سنشهد منتخبًا
فرنسيًا جيدًا والفوز بالنجمة الثالثة
وسنكون بطلًا واحدًا مرة أخرى
[تصفيق]
لذلك لدينا الآن تذاكر المباراة
لمباريات فرنسا الجيدة فقط
وبضع مباريات أخرى مثل المغرب
وإسبانيا والبرازيل ولكننا  نكون  في محاولة للبحث عن
طرق للحصول على المزيد من التذاكر
لتشجيع الأصدقاء في أي لعبة
صداقة أجنبية [موسيقى] لدينا ذكريات قوية
وهذه أهم نقطة في
التطبيق أعتقد أننا تعلمنا أيضًا
أن الكرم واللطف ليس لهما
قومية و  لأننا رأينا هذا في
كل دولة زرناها
[موسيقى] ،
نعلم أن الكثير من الأشخاص
يتابعوننا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ونأمل
أن تتمكن من إعطائنا بعض الأفكار لهم ،
على سبيل المثال السفر بالدراجة
من أسبوع واحد أو أسبوع واحد في  أيام الأربعاء
أو أسبوع واحد يمكن أن تكون جيدة حقًا
ونعم إذا كانت تعمل مع شخص واحد فإن
الرحلة كانت منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى] أجنبية